this is the end of days the end of days
like this it is not really the end of
days coronavirus is bringing a plague of
dangerous doomsday predictions in the
summer of 2008 an elderly psychic who
claims she started receiving
premonitions at age five published a
book that contained an ominous
prediction in around 2020 a severe
pneumonia like illness will spread
throughout the globe attacking the lungs
and the bronchial tubes and resisting
all no treat all known treatments it
said almost more baffling in the illness
itself will be the fact that it will
suddenly vanish as quickly as it arrived
attack again ten years later and then
disappear completely Oh that'd be
wonderful we woke up next like tomorrow
everybody's cured but what if you woke
up tomorrow and you were like so what's
going on the outbreak and then we all
just like one like this what outbreak
Adam the world is fine
and what I would rip your beanie off be
like Tim I save you yeah they say the
prediction faded from public memory and
the book's author Sylvia Browne died in
2013 but the crota virus pandemic has
brought new attention to Browns book end
of days predictions and prophecies about
the end of the world it shot up to
number two on Amazon's nonfiction chart
and physical copies are now selling for
hundreds of dollars you know I can
explain this very very simply to you and
I'm gonna use something that I kind of
learned from Penn & Teller your name is
John John I'm thinking of a number
between 1 and 15 and guess what oh no no
no I'm sorry I want you to pick a number
between 1 and 50 and John you picked 23
the gag is Penn & Teller did this where
with enough people watching most people
will just be alike my name's not John
and I didn't pick 23 yeah but for all of
the people who are named John who did
pick 20 feet are going nuts
what did you do that yeah and it's
because I just it's random it's just
probability mm-hmm so here you have a
lady or a book guess what I'm sure there
are like 500 million books from people
who claim things and we don't care about
any of the books that got it wrong right
so it's like it's it's like you're see
the Plinko game yeah you know it's like
you've dropped the ball
around yeah if you dump a hundred balls
and a little thing it's gonna you're
gonna get one in one of the slots yeah
congratulations
yeah now that I've rained on everyone's
parade a little bit more they say
government and public health officials
have issued all sorts of guidelines to
help people protect themselves against
the spread of kovat 19 but there's
another contagion that experts seem
helpless to stop the plague of prophets
warning that the corona virus is a sign
we're at the end of days there is
something about pandemics that caused
panicked people to empty their minds
along with supermarket shelves and
replace it with toilet paper I guess
countless doomsday warnings like Browns
prediction are spreading online blending
coronavirus fears with everything from
political paranoia about a one-world
government controlled by the UN to
Australian wildfires and swarms of
locusts in Africa well there are
literally swarms of locusts in Africa
and that's one of the plagues isn't it
yeah is the corona virus of plague pots
and boils was but this is not that no
this is people dying because that was
the end well that was the end plague was
everyone died really yeah dude killing
everyone did we miss the part where the
firstborn got like I'll snatched up was
that one of them was that not a plague
that was a plague it was and I don't
remember Passover they put blood yeah
yes so this is actually happening to
this out there's some crazy videos man
East Africa faces DualShock from
coronavirus and locust swarms dang yeah
dude already being ravaged by the worst
infestation of desert locusts in 70
years
East African economies are now staring
down the barrel of the corona virus
pandemic the region was on what was the
standout performer for economic growth
in the subcontinent prior to the locust
outbreaks which threatens the food
security and livelihoods of 25 million
people and has required emergency
funding of its own from the UN and
international governments now it gets
even weirder China launches huge fight
back against biblical plague in the
Middle East now this one's weird from
March 9th because it includes China
fighting in the Middle East against a
biblical locust swarm it's like a
perfect storm of weird like common moves
events locusts China
biblical Middle East all just mashed
together in one yep but hey
right this is from expressed echoed at
UK they say what does it say China has
launched a huge fight back against a
swarm of locusts of biblical proportions
which has now seen Pakistan declare a
state of emergency is there a video of
the locust maybe whoa are those actual
pictures there's just some planes what
is this
oh just people from China right locusts
the Middle Eastern country became the
latest victim of a swarm of locusts that
have wreaked havoc across East Africa
for weeks endangering economies in a
region heavily dependent on agriculture
for food security
heavy rain Xia we get it show us the
locusts oh there they are now the funny
thing is on their own their cute little
grasshoppers ah but together they're a
swarm of vicious crop ravaging monsters
that make scary sounds so they're gonna
talk about China providing you know
cargo and supplies I'm not super
concerned about you know what China's
doing just the fact there is a locust
swarm yeah and the interesting thing
about everything's going on on Netflix
what do you pull up Netflix the other
day because the number troop like the
top 10 movies half of them are outbreak
pandemics and yeah everyone's watching
apocalypse movies everyone's like let's
just dive as deep as we can
yeah it's not my uncle's say something
about that he's like why are we doing
this this is really strange to me I was
like no we kind of want to know what's
gonna happen and you have this affinity
for stuff that we're like we're in the
movie most of these movies are terrible
scary I haven't seen oh the Cajuns good
I got to see that it's contagion isn't
like a regular movie know that like it's
it's interesting because it files a
bunch of different characters doing a
bunch of different things okay but the
craziest thing right now is this viral
video where this dude he's filming CNN
and go
it's Sanjay Gupta sang increase your
social distancing we need to you know do
XY and Z here's what we can expect and
he's like wait a minute then they turn
to another screen and it's the movie
Contagion where Laurence Fishburne is
saying the exact same thing to Sanjay
Gupta serious in the movie anyway like
did this dude just say the exact same
thing to the guy who sang it now he's
like nah
movie man crazy in a movie there's
another doomsday prophecy thing
happening right now that's not really
that relevant this is from the Catholic
news agency which I might add is
absolutely certified as a credible news
organization by news and they say like I
can't what is this magic Gorji visionary
says monthly apparitions have come to an
end this story is about a woman yeah
yeah okay so well that's the town she's
in Bosnia and a woman who claims to be a
visionary of the Blessed Virgin Mary in
the bosnian town of Medjugorje a court
has said that Mary will no longer appear
to her on the second of every month as
she has reportedly done monthly since
1987 a legend Marian apparitions have
long been a subject of controversy in
the church which had been investigated
by the church but not yet authenticated
or rejected so the alleged operations
began in 1981 when six children a town
that is now that that a town in what is
now Bosnia and Herzegovina began to
experience phenomena which they've they
have claimed to be apparitions of the
Blessed Virgin Mary according to these
six seers the apparitions contained a
message of peace for the world a call to
conversion prayer and fasting as well as
certain secrets surrounding events to be
filled fulfilled in the future the
fasting thing to me sounds like you know
lose some weight man could you imagine
if like apparitions were really just
like like aliens came and they're like
dude I've done the fork bro and they're
like they told me to fast well I guess
that's why just this one person it's six
people oh 6:06 ears since their
beginning the alleged apparitions have
been a source of both controversy and
conversion with many flocking to the
city for pilgrimage and prayer and some
claiming to have experienced miracles at
the site while many others claims to
claim the visions are non credible
wasn't there a story we talked about
before where like they were licking
there was like a statue of Mary was
crying and I started licking it and
stuff sewage line yeah it was a leaky
toilet man maybe it's not true I don't
know it's the internet you know it's
true it's all true sir has it happened
on March 18th Soldo announced that the
Blessed Mother would no longer appear to
her at the time
according to the Caritas community which
identifies itself as the largest
Medjugorje Centre in the world
in January 2014 of Vatican Commission
concluded a nearly four year long
investigation on the doctrinal and
disciplinary aspects of the apparitions
and submitted a document to the
Congregation for the for the doctrine of
faith when the congregation has analyzed
the Commission's findings it will
finalize a document on the site which
will be submitted to the pope who will
make a final decision broke fan Pope
Francis approved Catholic pilgrimages
there in may 20 19 but he has not made a
deliberate deliberation on the
authenticity of the apparitions those
alleged apparitions still require an
examination by the church do we get it
they're not gonna say whether it's real
or not so wait so so people were
flocking here to like because it was
like a religious place where people were
having visions of the Virgin Mary right
right so now there's a like a pandemic
in the world and they're like no more
visions no more visions so no reason to
come here well no come here anymore yeah
maybe but they're gonna kick back up and
get like she's returned I'm sure
well I'm serious I'm calling it out well
we'll see but I it's it's it's we did
that story the other day about
Yellowstone pulsating yeah yeah that's
true it's 2020 you know no one ever said
2020 was the end of days well busy for
this girl didn't she oh no she just said
that they're smart prophets don't give
dates right why does CNN got a train in
our parade
look at this come on making fun of
making fun of everybody there's a
there's a long history of bad doomsday
predictions that's true
so when I lived in LA there was a
billboard and it said something like I
can't run that date was like June 16
2010 will be the end and I was like oh
man it's gonna be so funny when that
comes in passes and then he would happen
when it passed well they changed the
date really yeah and the guy apparently
was like I was three months too early I
misinterpreted the indie texts prophecy
and then like bro it's been 10 years
we're all still here yeah but I don't
know I guess people people just man they
buy into this stuff yes they do you know
you know you know what when I was little
my dad you say like you know what you do
if someone tells you the world's gonna
end but then you make a bet how much run
a bet yeah I'll bet you my life savings
so what does an NMR you know why because
if it doesn't
what do you what do I care savings for
and so they'll it's a win it's it you
can only win that's like alright yo me
hunt you know you owe me 10 grand or
whatever yeah
then there you go make the bet pay up so
I mean that's that's a good way to call
these people out yeah all right I tell
you what not even a big bet I'll tell
you what if the if the world
I'll bet like it's such a ridiculous
thing because of the world ends you
can't give the money anyway yeah that's
like we're all dead
yeah it's win-win so this is funny check
it out they say remember y2k how about
the Mayan apocalypse some people pointed
to the end of the Mayan Long Count
calendar on December 21st 2012 to
conclude it also meant the end of the
world they warned of giant tidal waves
and the earth would collide with another
planet sales of survival kits soared and
there were reports that a man in China
built a modern-day Noah's Ark but such
bad predictions aren't a modern
phenomenon you know it's funny or the
Mayan the Mayan calendar it's just the
end of the calendar so it's the
beginning of the calendar again this is
a joke do you know what the great year
is yeah yeah yeah the joke is to have
with people is what how would you feel
if I came to you and showed you a
calendar and I said it ends December
31st that's when the world will end
you're like no it goes back to January
1st I mean right exactly you're like no
no no calendar ends
there's no calendar after this calendar
I got a crazy story though for you you
know in the early 2000s because I used
to talk to my friends about all this
stuff daily the odds I've recently other
learned this yeah I love it it makes it
the early 2000s yes like dots yeah check
it out we were reading up on this stuff
mhm and one of the things we ended up
reading was that it said this was well
before 2012 it said the Mayans never
believed the world would come to an end
December 21st 2012 they believed that a
new era would awaken where everyone
could know each other's thoughts and
feelings to write her first social media
social media at a time everyone assumed
all my friends were like thinking that
meant like we'd somehow become psychic
yeah and we were like that's ridiculous
right like the world ending we roll our
eyes at but at least the world blowing
up is something you know but how do you
become second it makes no sense yeah
yeah twitter twitter verse YouTube
Facebook you can open up this blue
screen and see everyone's shower well
that's that's what was crazy to me
because I remember I'd even think about
this on
till a couple years later mm-hmm and I
was talking to my friends about it and
they were like we were talking about
some of the old things we had read and I
was like oh man
the way we read it back then made it
sound like it would be it would be the
dawning of a new age where humans would
have this great enlightenment instead we
did get this thing where we can hear
each other's thoughts but it's Twitter
it's a bunch of screeching banshees who
are angry at everything and offended all
the time yeah it's not some glorious
time it does feel like we talked about
earlier does feel like someone hit a
hard reset button on the on the planet
and it's like I mean thing humanity's
gonna change because of this yeah
all across the world people are dealing
with the coronavirus in different ways
but it's like in six months it's gonna
be society's gonna be a little different
have you ever seen a car pulling a
trailer start fishtailing yeah it starts
small wobbles crazier and crazier and
eventually just flips over yeah I think
that's what we're doing the longest time
okay
we were driving this car pulling the
trailer no problem yeah and then
throughout the past decade it's been
slowly swerving a little bit more and
more 2020 is where we're like swerving
like crazy and about to flip over yeah
yeah we got this I mean everything feels
like it's falling apart I mean the
economy is about to is just dead stopped
yeah it's almost like the simulation
just ended it's true and now they're
like well this is the end boys yeah you
know just shut her down
and that's where we're at locusts are
everywhere there's no checks just like
jellyfish are invading the sea there's
so much more
doomsday stuff that would even cover
yeah like the the jellyfish that are
appearing everywhere do you know the
story yeah they're everywhere all of the
fisheries are being replaced by
jellyfish erease really yes not what you
want overfishing so the void in fish all
the jellyfish come and now people are
harvesting jellyfish for food there's
like a whole bunch of crazy stuff
happening on the planet we had those
volcanic eruptions recently remember
that no it wasn't news New Zealand yeah
and then people just got like like I get
a volcanoes erupt you know but you
shouldn't be hiking around it just feels
like it's uh it's actually happening
no you know it's it's you know to quote
Philip J fry it's the waiting I can't
stand away the wait I like the way you
put it this time J fry yeah well we've
been watching so much feature Rama we
like or quoting it so
much well no no I feel like I need to do
a deep dive into Futurama so I can
understand all your reference it's a
great show no it is good I actually
really like it a lot
when we're playing when we're playing
board games we have feature AMA in the
background yeah and so it's like that's
where all these references are coming
from but I recently watched Kang and
kodos tree house of horrors the best of
the best of an episode or something or
it's the two aliens from The Simpsons
the two a like the big green tentacle
monsters and The Simpsons
okay and so in a while it was it was ID
off a long time yeah but dude the Bob
Dole Bill Clinton episode where Kang and
kodos take their bodies over and then
are running and okay so hilarious
no and then I don't I don't I don't it
wasn't this so yeah so there's a bunch
of funny jokes you should check it out
but there I don't remember which episode
it was I think it was the one where Kang
and kodos demand Maggie okay because
she's apparently half alien because she
got impregnated by Koto's with like a
ray gun or something okay but then when
they refused to give her up
they were like if you don't give it to
her we will go to York Washington DC and
purge your Congress and then Homer looks
at Marge and she looks back and he goes
you couldn't get all of that could you
and the like
watch us and they're like oh no that was
in the 90s that's pretty funny like the
approval rating for Congress thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you